so ich habe ja schon gesagt ich will und
ich glaube die bedienung fand mich ganz
nett weil ich habe zwei pommes gestellt
und pommes gibt es ja einen job und ich
wollte dann halt zu hause haben sie hat
mir viel zu essen geben auch noch auf
fünf leute was geht das spiel immer noch
runde greift automatisch was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video leute ich hoffe natürlich euch
jetzt gut falls ihr das vorne zu video
mit diesem greif automat noch nicht
gesehen habt check das auf jeden fall
nach diesem video habe jetzt so als info
weil ihr seht ja das ganze video wir
jetzt diesen automaten im hintergrund
wenn ihr wissen wollt was wir damit
gemacht haben er heute geht es aber
erstmal das fragt mich jetzt schon ab
nun hat man dieses leichte geräusche na
ja heute geht es auf jeden fall erstmal
ein anderes thema und zwar macht heute
den dritten part von der titel ist immer
so kompliziert heißen sex aus der tv
werbung oder ich habe beste video schon
gesagt eigentlich in jeder art von
werbung kommt so was vor und der
krankenwagen da ist jede sekunde war
schon vorbei fährt ist natürlich auch
ein paar von jedem meiner video
zumindest immer wenn ich hier also
mittlerweile sollte ja wissen denn jeder
art von werbung im c4 getrickst und das
was man da sieht ist nicht unbedingt
immer die realität und ich habe für das
heutige video wieder vier beispiele
rausgesucht an denen man ja sehen kann
wie sie eigentlich getrickst wird
natürlich kann es sein dass hier auch
nicht funktionieren das weiß ich im
voraus immer nie aber ich denke schon
ich wünsche euch viel spaß dabei wobei
ich direkt vorweg auch noch sagen kann
die tricks die wir heute machen die sind
gar nicht mal so schwierig also da waren
im letzten news deutlich kompliziertere
dabei aber gut ich würde sagen wir
fangen an mit wein ja also um genau zu
sein urteil den kann ich dann auch
direkt trinken dann wird er es von mir
nicht mehr so anstrengend wird so ich
habe eben eine extreme weinlese gekauft
wir haben nicht mal brechen unser
deswegen war das gar nicht mal so
schlecht ich meine vielleicht baue ich
dir irgendwann doch mal absolut die
anderen sachen abnehmen doch gar nicht
gezeigt wir haben auch zahnstocher die
sollten
das video schon einkommen wir haben
spender ja kuchen den wert für die sich
wieder brauchen lebensmittelfarbe
zahnpasta in kinder edition speiseöl
oder rapsöl war da und ich war gerade
von mcdonald's hauptzeit pommes und
burger co also wir fangen einfach mal an
mit dem rotwein ich möchte gerne drei
verschiedene versuche machen und zwar
schütten wir erstmal ganz normal kommen
hier rotwein in dieses glas ist eine
ordentliche portion weiß auch nicht das
teuerste hat glaube ich fünf euro
gekostet
anni die jetzt wieder schreiben wie
schützt oder brot weil ein ich bin kein
wein trinkt was man jetzt hier direkt
schon sehen kann
das ganze ist extrem dunkel ich kenne
das aus der werbung so dass es fast
schon ein bisschen leuchtet es muss ja
auch lecker aussehenden und ehrlich zu
sein das hier seht ihr als nicht
besonders lecker auch deswegen möchte
ich einmal ganz simpel testmethode ein
bisschen weinen hörten rein und füllen
das einfach mit ein bisschen wasser auf
ja schon besser auf jeden fall auf jeden
fall sollte man einen unterschied
erkennen sonst wieder das gleiche new
-t-shirts dritte möglichkeit wir nehmen
ein bisschen lebensmittelfarbe
[Musik]
also das mit lebensmittelfarbe habe ich
mir selber ausgedacht wollte ich einfach
mal ausprobieren das mit dem wasser habe
ich im internet gefunden ich würde sagen
das ist auch mein favorit also dass hier
sind wirklich nicht gut aus dass ihr
scheint jetzt irgendwie total und das
hier sieht am besten aus funkel so ein
bisschen hier mal kurz ein paar
jüdisches ist
[Musik]
so also das war der wein mit welcher
farbe sein mag ich kenne ja nicht so
gerne deswegen stehen wir dass man
schnell die seite gut dass ich mir
diesen riesen spaß habe jetzt kann ich
jetzt ein bisschen und alles wieder
sauber
so leute jetzt bin ich mal gespannt und
willkommen zum kuchen ich bei aller
dinge ist einfach mal hier auf dem tisch
letztes mal war die sache auf jeden fall
größere und jetzt werden hier ganz
vorsichtig zwei stück herausgeschnitten
so das reicht eigentlich schon so ich
habe jetzt die ganz schön einfach mal
das hier ausgemacht mit so ein bisschen
gremien zwischen
das zeige ich euch gleich ist in dem
beauty shot wir kreieren jetzt ein
geiles stück kuchen und dafür brauchen
wir eigentlich oder pappe hey das ist so
typisch hier fliegen immer so viele
kartons rum und jetzt wo ich mal pappe
braucht es keine da muss ganz dem keller
sowie haben wir das was wir jetzt machen
wir schneiden aus der pappe so
kuchenstücke die ein bisschen kleiner
sind als dieses stück diese größe sollte
perfekt passen und dann das gleiche
einfach mal jetzt habe ich hier zwei
stücke jetzt bauen wir den kuchen mal
kurz auseinander und kommt zudem
zahnstochern davon nehme ich einfach mal
drei stück so die pappe kommt genau hier
zwischen ja das nächste stück pappe auch
und oben kommt der deckel drauf das
schwierigste ist jetzt die zahnstocher
ja ja und sagt das ganze muss ja gegen
befestigt werden und dann schneiden wir
die einfach abgetaucht mir einfach mal
zahnpasta besorgt natürlich kann man
auch ganz normal zucker system aber ich
wollte einfach mal ausprobieren
[Musik]
ich habe mein bestes gegeben aber das
ist ja schlimm ich glaube zwar an was
eignet sich da nicht dafür naja aber es
ist okay an sich geht es ja nur um das
prinzip wie es gemacht wird
ich sage mir noch mal ich bin kein profi
hier meist die judiths dann kann man es
ein bisschen sehen und damit bin ich
jetzt zum beispiel überhaupt nicht
zufrieden ich könnte das jetzt noch mal
versuchen das problem ist die zahl
erfasster tour bisher können wir haben
nicht mal die zähne putzen
[Musik]
leute aber schaut man wenn man das jetzt
hier ein bisschen verstreicht sieht aus
wie eine leckere erdbeertorte also
zumindest ein bisschen
ich habe jetzt mal kurz ein teller
gewollt weil der tisch ist schon voller
grüner also sorry dass das jetzt war das
nicht so geklappt hat wie ich mir das
vorgestellt habe
aber das passierte kommt fortuna ließ
muss ihren die kommentare es ist sogar
noch ein problem ich weiß doch du bist
so viel mühe und so ich habe schon
gesagt ich war dann doch nicht und ich
glaube die bedienung fand mich ganz nett
weil ich habe zwei pommes bestellt und
pommes gibt es ja ein ding und ich
wollte dann halt sie zu hause haben sie
hatten wir viele chancen geben auch noch
als wenn man ne pommes auspackt dass wir
mal so aus der werbung vieles allerdings
nicht so aus für den trick braucht mir
ist noch diesen schwamm mehr brauchen
wir nicht den muss ich nur mal kurz
durchschneiden und der kommt dann
einfach rein passt perfekt
jetzt kommen wieder sondern zahnstochern
und das dauert jetzt ein bisschen weil
ich muss jetzt die schönsten com ist
raussuchen und die ganz entspannt so
drauf schieben
bis gleich
zehn jahre später ich glaube das sollte
reichen um euch zu demonstrieren wie in
der werbung dann eine große promis
ausschauen sollte ich habe jetzt hier
komplett aufgespießt und was wir jetzt
machen ein paar promis kann ich jetzt
einfach noch so rein legen weil die sind
ja stabilisiert und so könnte das dann
fertig aussehen um euch das jetzt noch
mal zu demonstrieren pana aufnahmen
beauty shot let's go
[Musik]
heute machen wir weiter
ich weiß dass hier wieder aus wie full
des chaos ist kein problem ein gesagt
haben wir denn nicht nur und zwar ist
dass dieser burger ich habe ein big bag
gewählt weil ich weiß nicht ob ich
glaube damit geht das am einfachsten
wenn man ihn auf macht sie das gar nicht
mal schlecht aus eigentlich ich glaube
das ist ein beispiel für den big mac der
relativ mit liebe gemacht wurde sagen
jetzt mal so sieht allerdings auch
keinen so aus wie in der werbung
deswegen gibt es heute ein trick dafür
braucht mir wer hätte das gedacht war
wieder eine menge zahnstocher und den
schwamm beschneiden wieder ein kleines
stück ab vom schwamm und trennen das
einfach mal diese beiden stücke sollten
eigentlich schon reichen natürlich hätte
ich jetzt auch noch extra salat kaufen
können und so sind habe ich vergessen
um ehrlich zu sein aber ich denke so
sollten wir das auch hinkriegen dazu
bauen wir den big mac erst mal
auseinander positionieren dann einem
schwamm den wir mit dem zahnstochern
fixieren
[Musik]
jetzt noch schnell das zweite stück vom
schwamm und zack und schon als unser
backpack gefühlt doppelt so hoch
natürlich kann man jetzt noch ein
bisschen mit salat spielen und
meinetwegen auch bisschen soße drauf
ballern und schon haben wir ein kleiner
unterschied hier kommen die nahaufnahmen
für spaß
[Musik]
leute das war's mit dem video
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen ich esse
jetzt erst mal hin ein paar pommes wenn
ihr sagt mach bitte noch ein vierter
part wird gern jetzt noch nach oben und
checkt man installieren da kommen die
nächsten 365 tage jeden tag ein foto ist
wegen würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr
folgt und wir sehen uns eventuell morgen
schon wieder das war es von mir
haut rein und will wenn sie sauer so
sind fünf habe ich jetzt den fünffachen
warum tust du denn fünf reihen so also
finde ich zwar sehr nett von dir aber
fünf ist auch schon viel
das ist ja viel zu viel für zwei große
pommes